assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the show i'm eddie your whole
subscriber if you haven't already we got
an exciting episode this is very going
to be very enlightening for a lot of
people
it's going to be sad for a lot of people
it's going to erect a lot of emotion so
some viewer discretion is advised my
next guest
is from is the president sharon slater
president of family watch international
now this is a coalition of organizations
around the world standing at the
forefront for the battle against
cultural imperialism and the sexual
rights agenda and what is that we're
going to find out their mission is to
expose the cultural imperialism pushed
by united nations and the western
countries especially the us and to stop
them from pushing a destructive sexual
rights agenda on families and children
worldwide
without any
do and without any
do let's go ahead and bring out our
guest
president of family watch international
sharon slater how are you sharon great
thank you thank you so much for having
me on your show
thank you for being with us here on the
dean show
so
talk to us a little bit about your
organization
churro family watch has been in
existence for a little over 20 years we
have something called consultative
status at the united nations and what
that does is that allows us to go in
when all the u.n member states are
negotiating documents and have an impact
on what is negotiated there so
we kind of have an inside view of the
battle in the trenches for the battle to
protect the institution of the family
and life and
we see and we uncover
the united nations agenda to sexualize
children and children represent the
future families of the world so this is
a huge attack on the family as well
hold on i don't understand united
nations you know
their
job is to i mean what did they have to
do with sex sexual education oh my
goodness that's a very good question
they really should not be in the sex
business but man are they almost every
negotiation devolves into a fight over
sexual reproductive health and rights
which encompasses sexual rights but
especially over something called
sexuality education and it would be
better named comprehensive sexualization
education because it sexualizes children
and raises them up in the radical gender
transgender and sexual ideologies that
all the un agencies
funded by donor countries in the west
are pushing
and this has been so your organization
has been exposing this for
20 some years yes yes
lots of research lots of webinars lots
of documentation
in fact
if you would i could you know show you a
few slides of some of their publications
because many people have a really hard
time thinking that well some people hate
the un and some people think it's the
savior of the world and depending on
which view you have
it's important either way to understand
the agenda that all of us are funding
because it's all of our tax dollars it's
funded by the different governments
which are all the governments in the
world
hold on hold on hold on uh sharon is
this some like conspiracy theory or
something that you know
that we're talking about are these facts
that people can go look up and check up
or yeah okay you know can i show you
things yes yes these facts can i show
you yes so one of the
the most urgent things
this is not some like conspiracy theory
is it no no i hope you know conspiracy
theories don't provide you proof and we
document and provide proof out of their
own documents that you can find on their
own websites and so you can check and
call out for beautiful because that's
what we're about on this program
evidence proof yes we would never just
make these you know broad accusations
without having evidence to show you so
can i share my
screen
yes please hopefully it will work
um
from my computer
let me see
you go ahead and figure that out we're
going to go ahead and play this clip
from i believe
your organization put this clip together
put this documentary together can get
taxpayer-funded
sex changes without parental consent you
can't have an aspirin at school without
parental consent however a student could
make these life-altering
permanent decisions
without the parental knowledge or
consent it's your organization uh
documentary sexual rights yes you'll
hear i'm the narrator again with doctor
alvarez you're the narrator yeah he
actually had pedophiles
measure with a stopwatch
how many children could achieve what he
called orgasms within a 24-hour period
today comprehensive
sexuality education is based on this
philosophy that children are sexual from
birth created by kinsey
[Applause]
got to stop it we've got to use
everything at our disposal we have to
stand together to stop this attack
against our children and they have all
this funding and this organization but
we know that if we stand together we can
do something for the family for the
children we stopped the kinsey sexuality
education program in croatia it is time
for parents to say no
what's this kinsey
comprehend is it kinsey comprehensional
educational program well kinsey is the
founder of the sexual rights movement
and he's the one that had um
pedophiles measured with the stopwatch
how many times children starting with
you know
very small infants all the way up to
like 14 years old how often they could
have orgasms within a 24-hour period so
we're talking sexual abuse they sexually
abused these children documented it that
came up with this whole philosophy that
children are sexual from birth and so
therefore we should be giving them
rights to sexual pleasure and teach them
how to have it and in different ways and
i know this is hard to believe but if
you i think i've just figured out how to
share um
i'll show you some proof of it yes
that's okay
um
okay so let me just
get to the top of this presentation
because i kind of put you in the bottom
okay
they're really after our children and
especially the children in africa
so
uh let's see here let me just you said
especially the children in africa
especially the children in africa in
fact i'm going to show you a program
that we're finding right now
if you go to this website
youngpeopletoday.net
this is a a coalition of u.n agencies
and donor countries that are trying to
get comprehensive sexuality education to
children and so they're trying to get 20
african countries to sign a commitment
there was one signed back in 2013 by 2
by 20 african countries and they're
working to get it renewed with the a
10-year future agreement to sexualize
children with these programs
they're trying the old commitment was to
get this this sexualization education to
75
of the african children in these 20
countries but now the these are these
are the governments that they're
targeting right now with their
sexualization
um
curricula and i'm going to show you
excerpts from it in a minute
this is called the eastern southern
african commitment that they're right
now asking these governments to sign on
december 6.
and if any of your listeners are
are from these countries or have
contacts in these countries we would beg
you to get in contact with them and ask
them to ask their governments not to
sign on and i'll tell you a little bit
more about that
but this is the coalition
of u.n entities and governments that are
pushing this sexualization education you
see all these u.n agencies international
planned parenthood federation really is
at the center of it and you'll see here
the governments of sweden germany and
norway and all sorts of other actors but
what they're pushing is called
comprehensive sexuality education or csc
and to understand that you have to
understand
how they understand what is sexuality
and compass for this sexuality education
well the world health organization has
defined sexuality to include gender
identities pleasures desires fantasies
eroticism and sexual orientation
so
this is the un agency's interagency
guidance on what children should be
taught about sexuality education
this came out in 2018 and can you
imagine the world health organization
even unicef that's supposed to protect
children and here's some of the content
of what they say children should be
taught
they are trying to redefine abstinence
saying abstinence is not just about
having not having sex it also is
deciding when to start having sex
and with whom
they want children to learn that each
person's decision to be sexually active
should be respected at all times
adolescent girls they complain don't
know enough about their quote-unquote
rights concerning abortion
they ask children to differentiate
between the values that they hold and
their parents hold about sexuality to
try to separate them from their parents
values wow
i mean i can go on but summarize the key
elements of sexual pleasure you know the
difference between gender biological sex
how to question the sexual norms in
their society
you know and really the whole end goal
is is encapsulated in this quote
they're trying to create demand
with csc with this sexualization
education
once they sexualize the children then
they're gonna need their youth-friendly
sexual reproductive health
and rights services which are their you
know abortions contraceptives
and even can that can encompass the
hormones for cross-sex hormones so this
is
really i mean the proof is right there
you can google this document no
conspiracy theory
um these are all the agencies behind it
but i don't know if you want me to
continue but i can show you some even
worse excerpts from a couple of other
manuals
yeah what comes to my mind is continue
on but why would they be in all these
organizations trying to sexualize our
children
very very good question um these all of
these un agencies if you think of these
u.n agencies not as human agencies but
as you know ngos or non-profits of
governments that's really how they act
it's whoever whichever government funds
them and gives them all the money drives
their agenda and so you have the
european countries and now the united
states under president obama canada is a
big player
funding these efforts because if you
sexualize children then they're going to
need contraceptives abortions and all
these different things and
planned parenthood profits from all of
this there's a lot of money in condoms
and contraceptives and and you know
the the purchasing of all these services
but really i believe the ultimate goal
is
the lgbt agenda and the abortion agenda
it's almost like a religion for many of
these european countries sweden germany
norway the netherlands finland you know
some one of their number one priorities
in their foreign aid is to advance lgbt
rights
and abortion and they can do that and
i'll show you some examples through this
sexuality education they can't convince
the africans or other developing nations
to adopt their kind of so-called values
sexual values so they do it by trying to
get to the rising generation to the
children and
they do it very deceptively they don't
show the curriculum to these governments
when they get them to sign on they say
this is going to prevent stds and teen
pregnancy and domestic violence and
sexual violence and you know you name it
they have this list that they tell them
that this comprehensive sexuality
education is going to solve but it won't
and
it you know it's interesting the
international planned parenthood
federation is the main driver and the
main tool that these governments fund
and use
they have 65 000 service points in 170
countries and so
you know this is unconscionable
this is their healthy happy and hot
brochure that i picked up at a meeting
for youth at the united nations and this
is a guide for children who are infected
or youth with the hiv virus they're hiv
positive and it tells them this is a
sexual rights approach to sex education
that they have a right to sexual
pleasure and they can get it through
these various verbs here you can see i
don't even want to read them all sucking
cuddling you know different ways just
have fun you know what sex you name it
and this is this is the main partner
that the un agencies are working within
funding but before you comment i have to
show you one more thing it actually
tells children
and youth that they don't have to tell
their sexual partners that they're
infected with the hiv virus right here
some countries have laws that say people
living with hiv must tell their sexual
partners about their status before
having sex
these laws violate the rights of people
living with hiv i mean unconscionable in
a in africa especially where you have
such uh high hiv aids rights rates in
the in these countries
you wanted to make a comment sorry
yeah
this is just so much to um
take in it's uh
wow just like you said deceptive
and
is this what's actually in the
comprehensive education packet this is
what they'll be learning this is from
that packet i'm showing that not the
actual packet these this is i'm showing
the underlying philosophy but i'll show
you what is in actual programs right now
just this last thing from international
planned parenthood federation to show
you their philosophy says young people
are entitled to sexual pleasure
and information on how to experience
different forms of sexual pleasure is
important to their health so this is a
right to have sexual pleasure no matter
what age this is what's in cse but let
me get back to no matter what age we're
talking about
five four five six seven year olds show
you the manual from the world health
organization for the european standards
for sexuality education and it starts at
newborn newborn to two years old teach
them how to touch their body parts for
sexual pleasure and about masturbation
then you learn about gender identity and
then at nine orgasm and and it's
terrible at nine years old
that this world health organization
manual for sexuality education tells you
to go to planned parenthood to learn
about your sexual rights
you know that document i just showed you
is where they would go learn about their
sexual rights from planned parenthood
you know the world health organization
sending youth to planned parenthood
world health organization sending
who again to planned parenthood children
yeah nine years old in their manual
in their sexuality education manual i
could find it for you and it would take
me a couple minutes to find i could show
you their manual um yeah to learn about
sexual rights so for parents in some of
these countries who might not understand
you know the conflict of interest here
where you're sending them pretty much
you know to the drug dealer who's going
to sell you to drugs to educate you on
the drugs exactly you have got it
but if you can imagine here is one you
see this document is called my body is
my body my life is my life this is the
sexual and reproductive health and
rights agenda
for young people by these un agencies
this happens to be for asia in the
pacific but they have the same agenda
everywhere i mean look at you know
unaids is supposed to stop the aids
pandemic unicef's supposed to protect
children you know we have all these
things but look what is in this manual
young people is def corresponds to ages
10 to 24 so they're talking we're going
to start with 10 year olds and we're
going to now go back go back please
because
for you know see this is for muslims
this is like the hijab you know this is
our yes
this is so is this a a young muslim
woman here
i believe that's how they're depicting
her you have you have some critic
but you have christians also in russia
orthodox christians who are also aware
so this can be either or this could be
but i would imagine that this is uh
an islamic you know muslim child um that
they put in here to show that they're
trying to reach everyone in these
countries um but
get a look at this
they they they describe secting sexting
as sending receiving or sharing sexually
explicit text messages photos and video
and you would think all these unagencies
that are supposed to protect children
would say okay this is bad don't do it
you can get the law you can go to jail
you can get extorted you know all sorts
of things no they say sexting may be
used to seek positive feedback on body
image from peers and therefore help to
improve self-esteem and sense of
identity
sexting for young people may be their
first expression of sexuality this is
particularly true for young people with
diverse sexual orientation gender
identity and expression for whom sexting
may allow private exploration of
sexuality and intimacy
sexting has the potential to be
beneficial as a way of sustaining
intimate relationships to demonstrate
love trust
i mean and commitment this is this is
unconscionable and you know policy wise
they're calling for the
decriminalization of consensual sex
which really means they just want to
lower the age of sexual consent so
children can be legally have sex with
each other
they want to decriminalize
same-sex
sexual activity they want to remove
mandatory requirements for parental
consent
to access srh that's sexual and
reproductive health services and
counseling so
if you translate that what they mean is
they don't want to have to ask the
permission of parents before they get
them in planned parenthood in their
partner's clinics
where they can give them with the
abortions those
contraceptives and they also the
counseling where they indoctrinate them
in their radical agenda they'll affirm
them in transgender identities and and
promote
and they actually train the youth to
advocate for sexual and reproductive
health and rights
and um you again asked for specifics in
a manual
this is the manual that was created for
this you know
esa commitment that we told you about
that's going to be signed on december
6th that we have to stop
this was the manual they created for the
first part of this where they had for
five years and you'll notice it's got
this logo here
advocates for youth we added this ippf
here to show you that they work very
closely with planned parenthood in the
u.s and abroad
to push planned parenthood's agenda and
they're actually creating the manual for
the africans
and if you go to advocates for youth
website you'll see they have a motto
that they put into all the un things as
well very similar our bodies our lives
our movement you know you just saw a
variation of that on the cover of the
manual that promoted sexting that i
showed you so advocates for youth
proudly you know host and and post the
african teachers module that they helped
create on their website
and here it has advocates for youths
circles of sexuality they want to teach
african children they're telling the
teachers this is what they have to teach
in africa gender identity sexual
orientation the human
sexual response cycle what that is is
how you can stimulate sexual organs um
and you know have orgasms i mean this is
really bad
it tells the teachers
if you're able to explore same-sex
relationships this is great
opportunity to normalize relationships
between gay lesbian and bisexual people
confuse them about their gender gender
identity means knowing whether one is
male
female
neither
as if that were even possible or
somewhere in between i mean this is just
radical and it actually again the end
goal is to get the kids use these csc or
sexuality education programs to get the
kids in the clinic so it actually refers
children in this manual to planned
parenthood clinics for confidential
services
or youth friendly services which is
really code for parents aren't around
and don't need to know about it
um
and also for abortion and abortion
services
counseling about abortion so yeah this
is the end of my slides that i have for
you um
if i did want to also show you the new
website that we have to try to stop
this please agenda if you if you would
bear with me i'll pull that up on my
screen yes absolutely um right now
this is what we're really concerned
about we need all your listeners to help
right now to do this immediately to help
protect children because on december 6
20 of these african countries esa stands
for eastern southern africa so this
website you can get to by just going to
esa commitment.org
esa commitment.org and here you can
click and learn about this commitment
and how this is going to obligate these
20 african countries to implement this
radical sexuality education that i just
told you about in to all the children in
their countries
so you can click on there and read why
it's so harmful what it is you can watch
the videos including that a full video
of the excerpt that was just shown you
on the show you can learn about watch
this video learn about what's their
sexual reproductive health agenda and
their sexual reproductive
rights and health agenda you can then go
back here you can click on here
and you can read about the 15
serious concerns that we have
with that agreement
including what they're going to be
teaching to children and how parental
rights are being violated how these
programs don't even mention
abstinence in the this this commitment
or marriage or fidelity it's all about
sexual rights but especially we want to
encourage your readers to go right now
to esa commitment
dot org and click on this and sign this
letter to heads of state you don't have
to be from one of these countries we
want an outpouring from all around the
world on this letter that's going to go
to eastern southern african heads of
state
some of the regional economic
communities here that are involved in
this agenda
this is going to copy their minister
foreign affairs and their other
ministers we're going to reach out and
send this to their members of parliament
and what it's going to ask them to do is
please postpone the adoption of this
commitment on december 6.
please do that because we don't think we
have enough time to actually stop it but
we're asking for them to investigate the
15 areas of concern but this is kind of
abbreviated version but just here's some
of the points it violates the
internationally recognized rights of
parents as i mentioned abstinence and
fidelity aren't even mentioned
sexuality how it's defined by the un and
yet this doesn't say it's going to be
defined otherwise
sexual and reproductive health and
rights services are not defined
how it needs a clause stating that this
is not to be used to promote a sexual
orientation or gender identity
how all the entities behind this have a
conflict of interest as we just
discussed how there's no oversight and
people can just click here and sign by
just going up to this field or clicking
there and we need people to sign it and
then send it to as many people as they
can and just just a few quick things the
esa commitment if you go to this drop
down
you click on the esc countries you can
see a list of which countries are going
to sign on to this
if you click here
you can see the text of the agreement
that they're going to sign
and we put in red all the dangerous
parts we don't have time of course to go
into which ones of those are dangerous
we have a great brochure that you can
click on
that shows you all of the um
different excerpts from some of the
manuals like i've just shown you here's
the oh here's the one that i told you
about the standard for sexuality
education for europe
these are quotes ages zero to four give
information about enjoyment and pleasure
and masturbation and gender identities
and same-sex relationships and so um you
know just a few quotes from all those
manuals you have that brochure you could
send that to people and help them
understand um here's a list of the
partners
in that agreement okay these are the
funders of the esa commitment and you
see it's all these same
actors that are just have ulterior
agendas
so
um
yeah we need to
then can we see that can we see those
countries the ones that are coming up
for this december 6 signing yes
these are the countries right here esa
countries ethiopia kenya lesotho
mauritius malawi madagascar burundi
botswana angola congo mozambique namibia
zimbabwe zambia uganda say shells
tanzania
that's what south sudan and south africa
so we have zimbabwe so we need all the
mufti's the sheiks the imams especially
we have one in zimbabwe mufti mink i
don't know if you've heard of him mufti
mink we need you to speak up he's a has
a very huge platform this is mufti mink
because he's from zimbabwe
and he has connections there with the uh
prime ministers the politicians that's
mufti mink we'll look at we'll look at
uh for some of these others there's a
lot of people from these countries that
watch the dean's show so are you saying
am i understanding this correctly so
these countries are about to sign
something so how does it work we're
going to give you some money because you
need to fix the roads or
build some schools or you need to feed
the
uh get some feed the homeless but now
you have to also we're gonna slip this
comprehensive sexual package in there
somewhere sold at the bottom you might
not even probably not even see it just
sign here and you get the money is this
something how it works um well that's
normally how it works that's how it
works when we're you know involved in
the un negotiations
and uh they're start to threaten to
blackmail or bribe and say we'll give
you all this infrastructure or
development money or this or that but
this commitment is very different the
money that they're committed for is not
for other good things
it's for this agenda now
granted you know i've showed you the bad
parts of the agenda right they create
this ice cream and they say okay we're
gonna stop child marriage and maternal
mortality and this and that and the
other thing and then they carefully
insert the cockroaches in that ice cream
right and they their real agenda is to
get cse comprehensive sexuality
education to be the answer to all those
problems even though it's it's not the
answer it's it's the right problems but
the wrong answer and their money is
going to go into this sexualization of
children and the clinics and the cse
programs and rolling it out all across
the the country to every single child
that's that's what the money is coming
for from all of these
entities i mean this is this is huge
right
and you know they're going to say that
csc is going to solve all these problems
but if you click on this csc research
there's a major study that came out that
showed an 87 failure rate for csc and 89
failure rate in africa and that many of
the programs actually increase sexual
risk taking and so
you know they any studies that they
point to cannot show any success in
preventing teen pregnancy in stds um
they they usually find findings of
process like how many children they
reached or but they don't have good
outcomes that they can show because
their programs sexualize children
sharon thank you very much we're out of
time sharon slater president of family
watch international thank you so much to
sharing your time with us and bringing
this
attention to the viewers uh this is
something that now hopefully the people
are watching this they can go ahead and
follow the direction that you're given
so they can sign this petition and help
to get the word out regarding this great
thank you we just tell them to go to esa
commitment.org that's
e-s-a-commitment.org please
sign the letter get others to sign the
letter
contact your governments tell them not
to sign on to this agreement on december
6. thank you so much thank you god bless
you thank you for everyone